yes another grieving family and yet
another death of a black man
that exposes this country's problem with
policing
[Applause]
Tyree Nichols is seen here indulging his
love of skateboarding on the video that
shows him beaten by police he's held to
call out for his mother
when you hear that your son was calling
for you three times in his final moments
what goes through your mind but for me
to find out that my son was calling my
name and I was only your feet away it
was did not even hear him
you have no clue how I feel right now
no clue
the five officers involved in the
incident all black men have since been
fired and now face a number of charges
including second-degree murder it's
about police officers
having this
biased belief
that you can get away with doing certain
things
to Black citizens and brown citizens in
America that you cannot get away with
with white citizens
in this quiet Memphis suburb Tyree
Nichols was pulled over by a special
policing unit known here as the
Scorpions
when police caught up with him they beat
him for several minutes the events were
captured on police body cameras and
other recording devices in these streets
the authorities in Memphis are going to
release the footage with trepidation
President Biden has spoken by phone to
the family of Tyree Nichols together
they've called for calm ahead of the
video release it will be difficult to
watch on a difficult day in this city